If we discover aliens, we’ll probably
see them because of their farts.
The first signature of extraterrestrial life is
likely to be unnatural compositions of gasses
in the atmosphere of a distant exoplanet. Think
of the Earth, the atmosphere is full of oxygen,
and this is only true because it keeps on
being replenished by plant and microbial life.
If life disappeared so would the oxygen. So if we
see a distant planet with an atmosphere where the
proportions of gasses are inexplicable by the laws
of chemistry alone, like lots of oxygen, or a mix
of carbon dioxide and methane but with little
carbon monoxide, this would be a biosignature,
a strong indicator that at least microbial life
exists there. To confirm any large creatures,
we’ll just have to visit. But how do we know what
chemicals the atmosphere of a distant planet
contains? The answer is atomic spectroscopy. If
we see a planet passing in front of it’s star,
some of that starlight is absorbed in a very
specific pattern called an atomic absorption
spectrum. Each element has a specific pattern
like a barcode, so through careful analysis of
the light it can tell us which gasses are
in the atmosphere and their proportions.
We already use this technique for other
space objects like stars and nebulae,
measuring properties like temperature, density,
ionization and relative velocity. Think about how
cool this is! We can look into deep space and
get so much information, just from the light.
It is like a gift that the laws of physics have
given us and we’ve used it, most of our knowledge
of the universe comes from this technique.
I’ve previously mentioned atomic spectra in my map
of quantum physics video and because this subject
is so cool I made this video to dig deeper.
There are two kinds of atomic spectra: absorption
spectra which is where the light source is behind
a gas, and the gas absorbs and scatters certain
wavelengths of light leaving dark lines in the
spectrum of the star. The opposite is emission
spectra, which is the same process but seen from
a different angle. Now you are only looking
at the re-radiated light of this nebula.
Here it is worth noting a few things. A hot gas
on its own emits light as an emission spectrum,
here I’m drawing the intensity of the light on
the vertical axis. A hot solid emits a spectrum
at all wavelengths called a thermal spectrum, and
so you can’t tell what the object is made of from
only how hot it is. And a star emits a combination
of a thermal spectrum with an absorption spectrum
superimposed on top which comes from their upper
layers. So in atomic spectra, why do we get these
very specific lines? To answer that we need
to delve into the world of quantum mechanics.
Light is absorbed and emitted by the electrons
in atoms and these electrons can only exist in
certain energy states which, plotted for
hydrogen, look like this. The reason for
these discrete energy states is that in quantum
mechanics electrons are described by a wave called
a wavefunction, and this wave can only vibrate at
certain frequencies in the constraint of the atom.
Just like a guitar string only vibrates
at certain frequencies in the constraint
of being tied to the guitar. These waves are
standing waves, and each higher energy wave
includes an extra half-wavelength and oscillates
at a higher frequency. I’ve simplified the drawings
to one dimension but in reality these are actually
three dimensional waves because the electron cloud
is three dimensional. There are an infinite number
of energy levels because you can keep on adding
one more half-wavelength to the electron wave, but
the difference in energies between these levels
gets smaller and smaller because the difference
between the waves gets smaller and smaller.
The biggest difference in energy is between
the ground state and the first excited state.
When light shines on atoms, if it contains light
with the same energy as one of the distances
between energy levels of the electron it can
absorb that light and the electron jumps to
a higher energy. Then later it will jump back
down to the lowest energy, emitting the light
in a random direction. This is why we see the
dark bands in the absorption spectrum, because
the electrons are absorbing the light then
scattering it mostly in a different direction
to the original light. So it is taking
out those frequencies of the light. And an
emission spectrum is just made of that scattered
light. Light is made of particles called photons,
and the energy of a photon is based solely on its
frequency which you can see from this equation
E=hf where h is a constant called Planck’s
constant. Also the frequency and wavelength are
related to each other inversely by this equation,
where c is the speed of light in a vacuum.
Here we have part of the emission spectrum for
hydrogen. You’ll notice that there are three groups
of spectral lines. There is a good reason for
this. The first group, called the Lymann group,
is made from all the decays from high energy
states down to the ground state. The other
groups come from energy decays from above
down to higher energy levels in a similar way.
That’s why the lines are grouped like this. Note
that this is not to scale, in reality these lines
are far more spread out in the wavelength scale,
and there are more series at longer wavelengths.
You should also note that I’ve been using
hydrogen as examples because it has only
got one proton and one electron, so it
has got a relatively simple spectrum.
But the spectra of other elements are more complex
and a real observation of many many different
gasses overlapping is incredibly complex.
Now you know all the basics of atomic spectra,
but it is also worth knowing about fine structure
and hyperfine structure. These are where,
if you look at a spectral line really closely
you’ll see that they are often made of two or more
spectral lines that are incredibly close together.
The atomic spectra we’ve talked about so far are an
idealised model, but when you add in the spin of
the electron and also relativistic effects you get
the fine structure splitting of energy levels.
And beyond that the hyperfine structure is seen
as small shifts and splittings of these energy
levels caused by interaction between the electrons
and the nucleus through their mutual magnetic
or electric fields as well as other effects.
Now it is important to note that what I’ve
described so far isn’t the only way that light
interacts with matter. There are a few other ways
that you should know about. The most common is
scattering which happens when electrons are
free to wiggle about when light shines on
them called Rayleigh scattering. You don’t need
the rules of quantum physics to describe this,
it is a classical effect of light being a
vibrating electromagnetic wave which interacts
with the electric charge of the electrons
causing them to wobble and then become
an oscillating source of more electromagnetic
waves which radiate out in all directions.
This scattering called Rayleigh scattering is
what causes the blue colour of the sky and the
red colour of sunsets. It is also why metals
are very reflective, because they have loads
of free electrons that move around very easily.
We’ve also got Raman scattering when light shines
on molecules, and can vibrate the molecules in
different modes and has its own spectroscopy
called Raman spectroscopy. And there’s also
Brillouin scattering where light can lose or
gain energy when interacting with vibrational
waves in the atomic lattices of solids.
Finally let’s look at the applications of atomic
spectra. I’ve already mentioned the array of uses
in astrophysics. The other main use is to see
what elements and compounds something is made of.
This is used in chemistry labs to see what
a sample is made of. Or even using the
hyperfine structure to delve into the nucleus with
nuclear magnetic resonance and other techniques.
Lasers come from controlling the
emissions from specific energy levels.
We can also harness the accuracy and repeatability
of the energy levels. For example atomic clocks
all need a standard oscillator to keep the same
time, so use the light from a specific hyperfine
transition of the cesium-133 atom which is
also how the SI units of distance the metre
and time the second are defined, and so this
also sets the definition of the speed of light.
So that’s my introduction to
atomic spectra, very cool stuff.
I’ll be looking at other topics from the
map of quantum physics in the future, so
consider subscribing if you want to catch those,
this poster is still available on DFTBA as well.
And if you value my videos and would like to help
support me make them I have a patreon page where
you can donate anything from a dollar per video
and get access to some behind the scenes material,
lately I’ve been posting work in progress scripts,
and images and video previews before they go live
on youtube. But no obligation, I appreciate
you watching and I’ll see you on the next video.